I used to be on zeolite and put that in my greens first rig since it was discontinued.
So this person's talking about a product called zeolite.
It was actually with the ze, I think, from Premier Research Land.
So since that was discontinued, so Premier Research doesn't have that product anymore.
I've been an ultra-binder.
Someone recently said that charcoal can bind two nutrients to, and not just to toxin.
But I take the ultra-binder separate from the green string.
Yes, so technically you should take your binders on an empty stomach.
It's good to take a binder in the morning and in the evening.
zeolite does act as a binder, but you're not taking zeolite.
So the ultra-binder, I would say, yeah, take that.
Don't mix it with the grades.
That would be perfect.
Again, you know, some people just mix all their stuff together and take it twice a day if they can.
Once a day, if they can't, you just have to have a balance in your life.
Yeah, in a perfect world, take your binders away from food.
That's the best way to do it.